يشعر الأوكرانيون بخيبة أمل شديدة لأن
الحكومة الألمانية الجديدة
مترددة للغاية في الانضمام إلى أه
الحلفاء الغربيين الآخرين بريطانيا العظمى
وتركيز الأسلحة الدفاعية إلى أه
لأوكرانيا لتقوية جيشنا أه
آخر قرار بإرسال هذه الخمسة
آلاف خوذة
أه هو  إشارة جيدة على الأقل أن
الحكومة الجديدة بدأت في إعادة التفكير في أنها
سياسة
تقييدية
لكنها أه ليست كافية هناك العديد من
الأسباب التي تجعل أه ألمانيا لا تزال
ترفض أي شحنات أسلحة
لأوكرانيا أحدها بالطبع
هذا
التبعية
من أم الروس  الغاز
وهناك عدد من القضايا الأخرى على سبيل
المثال الخوف
من استفزاز
بوتين لبدء هذه الحرب الجديدة أعتقد
أنه لم يفت الأوان بعد لتغيير هذا
الموقف والآن لدينا نوع من
لحظة الحقيقة حيث نحن  يمكن أن ترى
من هم الأصدقاء الحقيقيون لأوكرانيا في هذا
الموقف المأساوي للغاية